hey when you're doing bad friends with
andrew santino do you guys ever start
doing it and go this sucks let's redo it
last sunday we did one for an hour and a
half
and we at the end of somebody said
i think i said
at the end i go yeah this is honorable
and he goes what he's on terrible he
goes i know
i go what's wrong he's like i'm tired
i'm tired too we're not connecting
all that stuff that hour and a half was
a waste
he goes what do you want to do
let's meet tomorrow so monday we met
it was better
not i they said it was better i didn't
think it was better but um
it happens all the time andrew and i
have podcasts that we can never air or
or we will
no longer have careers
you have an episode we have one episode
that's in a vault
where we went you know because we had
one of those days where i was like it's
not connecting i go why don't we just
experiment and let's just just do one
where
we can say whatever we want just
anything just anything to provoke so we
did one where we could say anything
right
racist things you know sexual things and
things that
will get us cancelled
and we had
the best podcast we could ever do
because it was just raw it was
so funny where i would have to grab the
side my side and fall on the ground and
go stop stop stop we got to stop i'm
going to die laughing
like it was so aren't you afraid that
somebody will get that narrative how
it's in a vault like i said you took the
tapes or the discs yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it's it's like um
it was so freeing
you know i wish in in many ways the
world was like that but don't you think
that doing a podcast you can say
whatever you want because they can't but
you can they can't cancel your podcast
who can cancel your podcast but the
problem is is is that when you say
certain things on podcasts
that aren't true
and they're strictly for comedy
you can lose your job
not podcasting but you can lose
corporate jobs right and you can lose
some friends you know i mean you can
lose there's certain things that you can
lose that i've seen happen
right yeah um
then that's all you're gonna say about
that
i mean there's really not much to say
about it it's like you know
you